good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this episode of the Friday review of
apps my name is reto Meier I'm joined in
the studio today by food channel good
afternoon everyone and today we're going
to do things a little bit differently
we're going to continue to try and work
on themes so the theme for today's
episode is news apps and that's been
liberally interpreted by our viewers as
news and RSS reading apps so that's a
lot of what we got in the moderator
queue this week so that's a lot of what
we're going to be looking at what we're
going to try and do is take a look at
some of the top voted apps from the
moderator queue and have a look at them
and see what we like what we don't like
and then right at the end I'm going to
spend a little bit of time showing you
what are some of my favorite news apps
and why they are some of my favorites
and see how they compare with what some
some of you guys have nominated so I
think we'll start off by providing a
little bit of context so I've put
together a list of what I want in a news
app which would make it my my favorite
news app so you can put that on screen
for us in there we go use app will you
shall it out like that list that's right
any of any of these items which a news
app doesn't have makes me angry as you
can clearly see on the graphic thank you
very much room in Europe for your
artistic skills here and in putting this
together so what makes a great news app
for me I needed to do a few things so I
needed to have no latency at startup so
I don't want a splash screen ever I
don't want to be presented with loading
or pulling down you know your news
articles please wait anything after the
first time I'll allow it the first time
seems reasonable because you can't load
data before your appt is loaded at least
once but beyond that I want to see news
and its freshness is up for debate but I
never want to be presented with an empty
screen or a loading dialogue I want to
have great notifications I want
notifications which are rich as in rich
notification from jelly bean I want them
to not be to interrupt so they just come
up when I want them and the content
needs to be relevant it needs to be
related to the things that I'm
interested in
mean breaking you stuff where there's a
really high chance that this is
something I actually want to see and
it's the same sort of thing for widgets
you know I want to have a great widget
that's resizable they can live on my
home screen so I can make sure I don't
miss anything important throughout the
day whoa yes this is really weird we
were streaming and they're not okay I
have a start streaming button again
uh-huh let's do this all over again
woohoo right this time so like terious
not again from the beginning start again
so they mean not extreme or what oh
there was streaming at some point no
somehow it stopped itself and it hit
this is a certain podcasting again sorry
ended holy what the hell this is so
wrong let's see
oh okay so everybody that was my fault
my fault E&E Lewis admits that it was
his fault it's a shame we don't have a
producer cam today because I feel like
putting in face to the to the name and
the blame would be useful in this
instance that you can you find me on
google+ and circle yen will be looking
at a post-mortem for that i'm in about
an hour's time but in the meantime can I
presume that that everyone has been
listening and viewing along since the
beginning yes that's a shame i think
everyone would really have liked to have
to see exactly how much I can do this
exactly the same way so let's bring
let's bring up my list of hopes and
dreams once again if possible Ian okay
excellent okay where were we so I was
talking about notifications and widgets
so the other thing that I want to have
similar to that is offline support so I
want to make sure that if I'm reading it
on public transport that every time I go
in and out of a tunnel or anything like
that I can when you're flying absolutely
fire here this is a marine submarine
India I think for me it's not as
important that it be like completely
offline but that it works in
intermittent situation right so if I
happen to click on an article you know
when I go underground or lose cell
connection or something it's student it
still works for let's say five minutes
yep so five minutes and airline mode I
think so I also want to have something
which is an experience similar to what i
get when reading a newspaper which I
realized dates me significantly but I
still kind of like that flow of being
able to sort of page through news and
see what's interesting see what catches
my eye so some sort of narrative some
sort of category browsing which lets me
sort of just jump between articles and
continue reading things which I think
are interesting what else I don't want
to read through the whole list you guys
it's been on screen long enough you can
probably see it by now but I they do any
other thing I want to call out is that
you know I do want to have fresh data so
I do want to have background refreshes
but I don't want it to drain my battery
so I noticed that after installing all
of the apps today that my battery life
got to twenty-five percent within about
four hours of installing them all
so that's a bad sign harder to judge
sort of when i install a bunch of things
at once but definitely an important
thing for anything which is going to
stay installed on my device is that it
keeps fresh but doesn't drain my battery
so anything is just a multi hard balance
to strike at it is it is a tricky
balance and that's that's how you get
the big box know with any of those items
with you I like to highlight you know
the fact that a nap would work well on
different screen sizes and has what
we've been advocating would be very very
nice because each one of us you know
have like multiple devices and was I
would imagine you know it's not uncommon
for regular consumers to have maybe a
little bit over one device 1.5 to 2 the
price is a half device when I had leave
Isis on average right here they have a
phone with a small screen and maybe a
tablet and Nexus 7 for example or a
tannish device so make sure your app
looks pretty nice and good job on you on
here something yeah let's shall we get
started this is going so to give you
guys a bit of background we're not going
to go into as much depth as we have in
the past on each app we're going to
basically buzz through the five apps
that we've got installed and try and
highlight how it fits into that list
which I showed you just beforehand and
then i'm going to show you two of my
favorite news apps to see how they
compare so let's get started let's fire
up a good news let's switch to the
tablet Ian please perfect so good news
good news is an RSS reader if i'm not
mistaken so is this tied to google
reader it is it is tied to the google
reader so when you first launch it it
asks you a which account would you like
to associate is app with so i went
through that authentication process and
it automatically pulls down from my
google reader list or my subscriptions
and all starred items so let's go into
the start auto cause it shows you a
bunch of apps but at first glance it
feels like it's so sparse so i guess
isn't it yeah it's basically white
screen we go for things on either end
we're looking at a 10 inch screen
if that's the layout that if that's the
only one layout that you want to do at
least put some margins on the tooth on
the two sides yeah feels very very
crunchy yeah even better you know
obviously is to implement the two pain
version to pick the tubing layout for a
bigger tablet screen size that would
seem like a pretty obvious thing to do
for that like this way you are going to
be doing a lot of navigation through
lists of categories and then trying to
read the articles so having the two pain
layout really going to simplify that
navigation ugly so there are different
sources available this tab into CNN and
I expect to see a lot of Olympics
related shooting on with the BBC if you
wanted Olympics curated news oh that's
right CNN so yeah there you go all right
so it's again the same sort of thing
right we've got this massive amount of
screen and it's just a lot of white with
a very small amount of text and loot and
new images at all oops let's go back to
BBC let's try to drill down to a
particular article it's a one-line
headline and if you wanna I guess go
into the website are you press the
website or the detail icon but it
doesn't show you anything so a lot
immediately obvious what how this app
works and what you're trying to do with
it which is which makes for an
interesting sort of challenge it
definitely isn't optimized for for
tablet devices if we switch to the to
the phone camera you'll see that it's
sort of a better layout if it is even if
not perfect sorry if you could die
switches across there and show the folks
at home perfect so you can see it's it's
basically it's exactly the same layout
it's just that that sort of small
paragraph of text here fits in a way
that's sort of much more easily readable
so it sort of they get they get that
right but it's clear that the the layout
here has been designed specifically
through a force more natural right if
that's the only one thing that you can
do as strongly suggest you know maybe
be adding like I what like what I said
before adding some margin to the left
and right that'll make it a bit net why
natural absolutely so let's switch back
to the to the tablet campus I know the
folks at home prefer the the
high-resolution one so let's see if we
exit out and go back in do we have any
latency on the first so open straight
back up to where we were before hand
it's good is nice and you can see down
the bottom here that it's kicked off a
synchronization which is which is nice
too early to judge how well it does in
terms of a battery life overall but
certainly it gets the no latency
solution which is good one thing it
doesn't do so you did the the initial
initial sign in profile so this was for
an account which wouldn't have had a
Google Reader account associated with it
did it suggests to you a bunch of
different topics and sources that you
might be interested in um I actually
didn't go through this year's gays I had
a I had an account with some articles
associated with it but that's a good
suggestion by the way so that would be
useful so you know again you want that
you want that experience so for all the
people they're going to download this
app specifically to read their Google
Reader articles but if for the people
who don't use google reader there there
are probably a few of them you're going
to want to basically provide them with
that sort of newspaper content if here's
a bunch of stuff that a lot of other
people think is useful so that's that's
definitely something i'd consider in
your float if it's not already there
that's very and in fact that's what the
google reader product that's right when
you first log on when you are the first
for a first time user it actually
suggests a number of articles so that it
you don't you're you don't need to stare
at a blank screen i'm going to know why
why use trying to simulate i'm going to
turn the Wi-Fi off and and see how we do
when we're offline alright see if we can
read this so we can see I can see on the
content mensita headline oh that's nice
I mean it's it's a new it's an RSS
reader so I wouldn't expect it to to
catch the links but it we can at least
go through here and read all of the read
all of the text doesn't have the images
again that's probably a reasonable
compromise so we can go through here
find out which articles were interested
in then we can star them or
for future yeah for future reference so
that's that's interesting so if I click
here it's actually allowing me to select
the mode for read read list or studies
that's a little bit counterintuitive I
would expect if I hit the star here for
Julia it's more like bullying right out
of Star it or not you know I think it is
actually so if i actually hit the star
it works its if i hit anywhere else on
the on the ok so it so it goes back to
the point where you know you want to lay
out your app properly more bigger tablet
screen exact source mall so these touch
targets are way too small i should say
these touch targets yet so we want to
make them much much bigger we can see
here so they're using a are using a
viewpager thought they were swears
alright so everything a few pager but it
seems so what aren't what are you paging
through is what the diff difference
particles within CNN darko what's case
using timeout sorry Oh be getting
handsome chose to me and I'm not quite
right we haven't we haven't agreed on
the hand signals you're supposed to just
shake your head or nod like like a
baseball wink excellent and I after now
i know i just want to mention the two
things first that despite earlier
promises you're spending an awful lot of
time on this particular app ok and
second that we do have steve from
vandroid my right guys up next yeah
let's let's move on ok so um thank you
for the air for the heads up because we
do tend to get a little involved so big
highlight here does work on on does work
online and offline biggest issue is that
you've got a huge amount of white space
so it doesn't create a really immersive
reading experience so you really want to
think about updating this for tablets
specifically all right let's move on to
android android news because we have the
Creator online with us so I'm sorry
what's your name again I house you see
good to meet you hey Steve thanks for
thanks for joining us so why don't you
why don't you spend a couple of minutes
and talk us through through the app now
what should we be looking out how
closely do you think it conforms to the
sorts of things we were talking about
earlier on
from what you're talking about early on
one thing that does not have yet as
tabulate layouts it's something that we
do plan on integrating into the future
but currently right now we wanted to
make sure that we get all the bugs out
of the out before we move on to adding
more layouts shrimp fest I think Rhys
you're good that's iterate right nothing
that makes sense um okay it looks like a
little bit of your screens dating or
nevermind so it's like I'm pretty
accurate what I so one of the things I
probably point out just you know looking
at on the tablet like this as you say it
looks like part of the screens getting
cut off and that's distinctly possible
with our av AV setup but it actually
does highlight a good point which is
that you don't really have any padding
around the outside so if you have a look
at the design guide it'll give you an
idea of what rhythm your app should
follow and I I think it's at least a six
pixel border around the outsider it
could be wrong on the specifics but what
you've got now makes it look a little
bit cramped so that everything is feels
like it's almost falling off the edge so
you just want to add a little bit of
padding around each of your elements and
around the edges of your layout to make
it feel a little bit more comfortable
within the app and you can see that up
the top here where you've got your icon
in the action bar it's that kind of
level of padding where you just want to
sort of bring everything in and out in
the same way that the action bar works
and it makes things just feel a little
bit more comfortable and also suggest
looking into increasing the font size a
little bit because if you look you're
looking at the category heading our news
starred there just a little bit too
small and then you have a week oh great
let's have a look at it I imagine is
under the overflow menu also say yo
let's check out the font size great tiny
Thank You MA large huge well I was
interesting so is that I take it at the
custom animation you put in there to
shake the string when you change the the
screen size of the font size requirement
sheet one I mean most people
for errors error dialog do something
there's a note section I quite like that
actually it all looks neat and one of
the things I wanted to point out to
highlight specifically about this out
that I like is the way you've handled
starred items as I've seen this done a
bunch of different ways and most
commonly your people will have a single
list whether start items are at the top
of that list and then so you'll click
something in the list and it'll
disappear from where it was and move it
to the top and that drives me crazy
because it really interferes with your
normal workflow what you've done here is
great because I can start all of these
and then they appear here on my start
list which I really like so you know
you're doing that instance star you get
everything highlighted in Australia we
have this list and if I want to remove
them I can take them off this list and
they disappear in that makes sense that
intuitive yeah so I quite like that and
it still keeps that nice simple
interface so I assume that all of the
news which you're displaying within this
app comes from phandroid and I see the
Refresh icon up in the action but what's
the Refresh strategy like is if Manuel
is a periodic or how come figure about
is it is it do is by default I'm a
background service that runs every 30
minutes now the limitations of weed is
only being able up there for 30 minutes
I Ingrid my own service right if you
need to go more frequent than that you
have to implement your own service some
people like every five minutes that's a
little overkill for me right once an
hour if I scented with no options and I
get a manual i think overall if you set
a default out-of-the-box refresh
frequency of 30 minutes a frequency
that's that's reasonable for a new site
like Android one of the things which I
talked about at my io talk this year was
trying to create something a little bit
more dynamic in terms of setting that
default so it's great that you give
users the options to choose but one
option which you might want to consider
is having sort of a dynamic sort of back
off to those updates so that you default
it 30 minutes but if if a user is
installed the app and they never
actually open it or open a very
infrequently then that 30 minutes is
suddenly really aggressive front because
you drain a battery every
valvo firing up the network you know
doing that download and I only open the
app twice a day so what I kind of
recommend you can do there is to
basically keep track of how often they
open the app or click on the widget or
anything else and if you go past the
interval of your refreshes then you know
double it so that ok they have it looked
at in 30 minutes I'm going to make it an
hour they haven't looked at in an hour's
I'm going to make it to 48 until you
just updating once a day and then as
soon as they do open the app and look at
it you can then go straight back to that
most aggressive 30 minutes so you sort
of trying to balance that battery life
versus the freshness based on how
frequently users are actually using the
app so it might be something to look at
that's good tip otherwise you know the
app the app looks good I think it's
really interesting strategy you've got
with your advertising Lee give people
the opportunity to turn it off if they
want to but make it clear that you know
basically by leaving the advertising on
there helping to support that the
website which i think is an interesting
an interesting take on advertising
supported right can I ask you how what
do you find the split is the most people
lead on to most people turn it off do
you have any sort of analytics around
that it really seems like a mixed crowd
I mean the hard core android readers
they like to salute you know hmm i think
giving them the option to do it or not
to do it it can't encourages them to
leave them on yeah all right it's like
you could turn it right you know you can
help help really helpful it's force'
mentally displaying as everywhere
possible you're going to probably just
go absolutely well it's interesting that
although you haven't explicitly optimize
your app for a bigger screen size I
noticed that the ad size they have
adjusted themselves to fit nicer on a
tablet versus the smaller at unit on the
phone yeah so yeah we we probably want
to move on again pretty quickly what I
like I mean the reason why we don't
spend too much time is because this is
nice and simple so it does exactly what
you'd expect it to do you know does the
update schedule which we talked about do
we do you have a widget for this
particular app
three ridges free widgets nice one is
just an icon of agent which was first
started to mimic of what a large icon is
not ended up removing actual title
because we actually happening under the
icon because I couldn't get it to be
perfect on all devices very very trying
to get that blue bro the other two one
get a stack widget once this news widget
where has left and right arrow buttons
and then also I have the stack review
nice I do like a stack widget and so
that's showing ice the first article in
each of the categories and is the the
number representing the number of
articles within that category or what is
the number represent numbers are
consistent with how many comments or in
your oh I see so it's each of the
articles because you only go have
essentially one category which is all
the articles on phandroid and then the
the counter is telling you how many
comments are for each article that makes
sense taking a big if there is if our
new articles which triggered by the
background service they'll be actually
with little bubble abideth android logo
things like how many were there are very
cool but you enter the app it will clear
that as counters or any notifications
either work here and there are new
articles which is different than read
and unread alright gotcha ok it's great
it's not so yeah so like I said we
should move on but the one last thing
that I want to mention in terms of the
the background updates you know given
that you've already got a fairly
aggressive timetable for for those
refreshes you may want to consider using
google cloud messaging so that your
notifying each of you users whenever you
get that its new article so rather than
waking up every 30 minutes or
potentially every five minutes for those
really hardcore users you know
presumably you guys aren't quite
publishing every five minutes yet so you
know you can sort of back that off by
basically just you know alerting each of
you uses when there are new articles to
read so that then the device can wake up
and next time it's connected it can you
can go ahead and get those updates
rather than
and all the device i right great yeah
the gear so GCM if you aren't familiar
with it google cloud messaging I was a
rerelease version of cloud to device
messaging which we released a google i/o
so there's no quotas or anything like
that which makes it kind of perfect for
this sort of thing where you want to
blast out a lot of messages to people
and it supports batching too yes this is
awesome just very handy cool all right
thank you very much for for joining us
and and will well I think we should move
on to a couple of these other apps while
we still have time thanks excellent
shall we try Rita yes let's look it's a
reader HD which sure if I'm not going to
see what day can I think maybe even
represent represented this in the
moderator queue is that writing is this
an app you're a fan off oh no my my app
is G reader pro 1 i'm eager to see if
reader HD beats it let's check it out
then so this is what this is again a an
RSS reader so presumably this is looking
at the same also for the same source
google rita google radiant with the same
account it's got a to pain you i switch
exercise itself nicely on the biggest
screen size like what we're looking at
and on the right pane you see on the
right fragments to be exact you see a
bunch of new listings with ability to
store an article i assume the article
has been start great and a check box
right here I assume it's definitely
whether you had read it or not and the
setup is pretty straightforward just
like the previous user apps that we
looked at very nice Rock be it shows you
it's jose an ad down down below in the
news item do me a favor a star one of
those so reticent brits for example i
give that one a stock i happen to have
the app open on a phone here as well and
i will see it magically magically update
you is it provisioned using the same
account it is the same amount cool yes
let's see if it's uneven magically does
it I rather suspect that oh no it is
refreshing so we'll see I suspect that
we'll have to jump back out of this and
and go back in before it'll refresh
rather than doing it
dynamically let's try that nope not yeah
let's go on and we'll report back we'll
report back exactly let's switch back to
the tablet all right so in terms of the
layout so this is interesting it again
is a lot of white space but it's white
space that is keeping it simple rather
than keeping it empty so we have you
know all the screen being taken up great
use of the action bar great use of the
split the split panel which are which
fred was describing earlier so it looks
it looks pretty good right yeah this is
a pleasant experience let's go ahead and
test the offline please yes I just
switched off the wife Wi-Fi during and
then let's go back to Rita HD and again
so there's no latency there so that's
dedicated and it looks like news
headlines I cashed yeah nice it's great
and read the oligomers wait rato happy
it does it does make me happy oh I'm not
going to be happy until you can view
original offline let's say thank you
original so it's just it's opening up
the dope native browser and and filing
so uh so that's so we have rato happy
not so much in our not so happy let's
see let's see if redeploy I think reto
is is not quite the connoisseur of
reader apps that I am this is this is
probably true I have to be honest I I
asked right do love g a google reader
but i do tend to use that on my computer
whereas what I'm on my mobile I prefer
to read just sort of news from new
sources all right let's have a look at
some we do have an newest greader pro
you're not over interesting so do you
read a pro I have it on this one so
let's uh let's have a look it's going to
scroll this down while I sign in
actually we can look at this fly I'd
like to see that email address so it's
using the the authenticator on the
device which is nice and it goes through
so this is interesting so the founder
adapted this as well during first load
it tells you what's new which is great
except for the most part people don't
care so there is a place on Google Play
to be able to say exactly what's new and
I certainly don't have any objection to
putting it somewhere in your overflow
menu but having it as
of the first thing you see just slows me
down if I click that icon I just want to
read some news I'm not particularly
interested in what's new in the app the
other deal breaker here is down under
notes oh if you like your radius of 5
stars yeah so this is a thing so if
there's been a lot of back and forth
even within our own team of how we feel
about apps which solicit ratings in
Google Play oh there's a very important
distinction right yeah between asking
for people to rate your app versus
asking for is very specific rating
exactly i think i think we've pretty
much all in agreement that when you are
specifically asking for a five-star
review even if you're saying you know
only if you like it then give it five
stars that definitely crosses the line
me personally i don't i don't like it at
all i just think look people know how
Google Play works if they like your app
and they choose to write that they're
going to do so asking them explicitly to
do it I don't think it's going to give
you a lot us out or but definitely don't
solicit five star reviews specifically
because you know it's kind of not kosher
so let's say let's close this and move
on so this is the the general layout so
they've got an action bar style bar
along the top which I have to be honest
I'm not a huge fan of because it's way
too small so you can see you can see my
finger in relation to those buttons as
the camera re positive actions are ya
and I mean they were all way too small
like I'm going to I'm going to miss this
and accidentally hit the wrong thing
it's also interesting because this ya
see I'm confused straight away because
you know I expect these to be actions I
expect them to be things which I click
in it it performs something so plus
should you know add a new subscription
which it does it throws you to a screen
that has a different look and feel it's
got a dark theme yes just the white that
the light freak theme that we were
looking at exactly so it's kind of its
kind of throwing me and I can I can
browse let's see net something i did in
a previous life so look at Scotty goos
blog
so this is all taking a little bit
longer than I would like because I'm an
impatient person so I'm going to hit
back and you know from here again so i'm
not expecting these to be to be to
function as navigation but its actions
and their kind of working as navigation
so if i'm clicking through these this is
switching between feeds and tags which
isn't even what i'd expect right so
everything here i would expect to be an
action and it's actually navigation so
if you're doing that with in action bar
navigation stuff should all be over on
this side next to the next to the the
app icon so this this is all fine so
this is just the overflow menu sort of
customized which we're fine with but
again so i would think about how you can
put these you know either as tabs or as
viewpager items something like that
might make it a little bit easy to
understand to stay up have you pleasure
it doesn't at this level at least so see
if i go through reload the articles then
yes so the articles themselves are and
so this is quite nice with the other
fade in fade out but it was fading and
fading out perhaps it isn't maybe i'm
just too quick but so these overlays i
think are quite nice i guess this is
going to let me increase the size of the
text but again all the touch targets are
a little bit too small and so it's good
that they're not obtrusive but it's
really hard to sort of click them and
understand what's happening there so
you've got it on the on the tablet now
as well so i did its idea let's switch
to the tablet was this what's the same
opening oh nice we already had a to ping
layout which is good excellent let's go
to engadget and look for some stuff left
hand side you know shows you other stuff
high-level titles and right hand side
once you've chosen a type a new source
you can browse through the various news
articles which is quite nice on the
right hand side and on the tablet I'd
say the touch target or a little bit
well this looks like a standard I katha
botany this looks like for the tablets
they've just gone with a standard
regular action by right that's local
it's much more than just feels more
natural not more natural
the tablet absolutely a touchable target
now let's take it offline we've done
that tool with the other apps will do
the same oh yeah and and see and we'll
see whether Ian's favorite app actually
does what ian was hoping it would do all
right by honest truth do you think right
it may indeed be an optional setting so
okay we'll check that may want to look
at some of the settings I completely
agree with you on layout this app
frustrates me no end but I haven't had
anything I haven't been able to find
anything that has the same features that
this does the specific things that I
like our it has if you if you read long
articles the viewpager will remember
where you were oh that's not so as
you're scrolling through so let's have a
look at this Penn State scandal that's
not long these are all short articles so
but if we've got sort of multiple pages
that we're scanning click through it's
going to automatically move right to the
right place in each of the view pages
that's correct well as i remember across
devices based on your experience
nobody's not that would be awesome
that's that'd be incredible oh yeah i
don't actually think it remembers for
very long mm-hmm but that's not usually
what I'm looking for usually what'll
happen is I'll be reading a blog let's
say and flick through to the next
article and then realize that I really
wanted to see something in the previous
article or I'll even activate the
viewpager by accident it can be very
frustrating if you're reading a very
long blog article to lose your place
like that the other thing that it does
is it automatically mobilizes the text I
think that might be a something that you
have to set I've seen other RSS readers
do this but if the if the blog that
you're reading is one of those where it
just has like a sentence or two of text
in the RSS feed what you can do is ask
it to go and fetch the actual article
and cash it offline which is exactly
what we're looking at on screen here so
in settings offline reading there is an
offline usage which allows you to either
enable disable or select for Wi-Fi only
downloading the article contents after
you've synchronized the headline so
that's that's actually a really
interesting feature
you know I want to riff off this idea of
being able to synchronize across devices
which is something that I think from a
game perspective I think a lot of us
have been asking this for a while so
that you can synchronize your progress
and I would love to see this across more
apps like news where you know I just
want to be able to fire up the same app
on multiple devices so I'm reading it on
my phone then I sit down and pull out my
Nexus 7 and be able to continue reading
the same things at the same place so
that it just feels like everything is
magically synchronized to it's obviously
going to need to find ways to identify
yourself on its various devices but you
know for users who do choose to do that
I think it will be a real advantage
that's a huge plus absolutely so this
this is nice so again I like the layout
here again using sort of that white
theme I would point out that down the
bottom here where you've got I guess
these are filters so we can filter
through these various items the
iconography here using the colors almost
it feels out of place compared to the
rest of the app so i think it makes
sense where you've got the names of the
icons associated with each of your
sources because they asked the things
people recognize the colors for but for
most parts within within the hollow
thing anything which is sort of a menu
item or an action bar item anything like
that tends to be a monochrome icon you
know flat monochromatic icon and I think
that would look much more in place and
who was the same thing here so I would
look look at that and floral design
guidelines exactly yeah and go through
them and I don't think that there's
anything specific in the design
guidelines fur because this is quite
accustomed thing but I think it would
just sort of fit I also noticed that one
of you text is getting cut off here
recommend and given that that from
sidebar is going to be you get to decide
how big it is you probably want to make
that a little bit bigger but also keep
in mind that I think Roman pointed this
out for an up we were looking at I think
yesterday is that we tend to this almost
works like tabs and we tend to suggest
that in tabs you should either go for
just images or just text rather than
both so in this instance I think just
just images as long as you can provide
icons which are obvious enough which I
think in this case everything but
recommended would fit into that category
but for many items it's okay if ya real
estate if there's enough room of a state
to include both icons and text
absolutely definitely keep that emo so
we have I think about seven minutes to
go so I think that's is that all see us
go through your favorite apps boy I want
to look at my favorite apps but um I
think these last two who at least
news360 is and actually a news app so I
just want to bring this up real quick
let's go back to the tablet p.m. thanks
perfect 360 view images in this category
latest news see what this is going to do
interesting oh is it offline possibly
yeah it may not be fair so it actually
work pretty well considering was offline
so yeah the sample of latest years
internet connection is required to use
categories but you have an internet
connection now I turn it off take some
time take a little time yeah and start
browsing alright so we've got an
internet connection now since again so
again this doesn't have a latency egg
yolk is nice rich display showing us
that sort of two panel option here so we
can see latest news we can sort of brass
or each of these it's a little bit slow
I would like for things to come up a
little bit quicker when I change
categories so you at least have the
boxes and the headlines and there's some
of the text even if it takes a little
bit longer for the images to come
through this is nice sort of like the
color scheme the overall colors yeah
absolutely it blends in pretty nicely
within the app absolutely you know like
nice use of a pseudo action bar I think
everything over here is a bit custom not
a fan of the of the of the settings page
at all all the settings icon you'd
better off here to use an overflow menu
with settings in there rather than run
it in your own consistent thing we go
back search using the built-in search
widget so I like that stay back so
hitting back should make the search
widget go away rather than make the appt
go away just a little tip there
so look with a 360 view so that's the
name of the app is 360 oh that's a grim
picture so yeah differentiate oh that's
like this app exactly so this is kind of
cool so we can scroll through the
pictures I'm guessing if we click on one
of the images we we get the ability to
read the article associated with it so
that's that's actually quite nice and
then the article view we have you know
it's obviously a very visually based app
whether the pictures are a big part of
what you're looking at that's cool okay
so that's having looked at all of those
other app to me in a few minutes we have
remaining I wanted to highlight a couple
of what all of my favorite apps so one
of those particularly for news is is
news Republic that's unexpected maybe I
was looking okay must have must have
already been using it so this kind of
follows that that thing that I was
talking about right at the beginning of
an app which is you know being able to
help create that narrative flow
something so I can open it up and just
sort of start reading and seeing what I
think is interesting so we have this
quick tour explaining what everything is
you know I'm to be honest a little bit
ambivalent towards these these helpless
screens they kind of feel like apps
should be obvious when you open them up
you should just stop being able to start
click things right think she just
happened you should be able to learn
what you're doing weekly news like with
all revenues before and for a new news
Republic in particular they've done
their the UI is very very intuitive
right there only two options you can
either go through the news articles or
search yes right so these for the most
part these functionalities that's a
pretty self-explanatory so to your point
rato I think the tutorial screen is
rather redundant in this case just
because again you guys have done a such
a great job in organizing the UI exactly
sorts of look so if we go into a
category so straight away they've got
some kind of interesting UI elements
there where you click on a on a category
and it does that sort of 3d fade which
is nice and it doesn't go on for too
long which is important so we look here
we can see all of the articles here on
the left we go straight away and this is
kind of important we go straight into
reading an article in the to pain view
so we don't sort of get the list
first and then have to choose an article
before we start reading the straightaway
get to start reading content don't think
there's a viewpager now there is
excellent so you can view page through
each of these and it as you view pages
as your real page through its
synchronize their carrots hmm so we can
see straight away and we can navigate
either either ways which is nice one of
the things so they've done that there's
a couple of so for the most part it's a
pretty standard news app where I like
the layout I think it looks really nice
there's a couple of differentiating
features which there which they've done
which I think a kind of cool one of
which is that you are able to this icon
here just on the top right gives you an
indication of how people feel about that
particular piece of news so if I click
on it it will tell me what people's mood
on whether they are Scottish pleased in
different worried sorry angry there's
there's a whole sort of set we can see I
haven't read the article so I wouldn't
want to wouldnt want to judge it and
then it will it'll tell you up here how
people are feeling so as you can see as
we go through here I assume there's me
indifferent to pretty much all these any
other news today go the top stories
because that's probably more likely to
have some opinions or possibly not ah
here we are so we can see three people
have an opinion on this most most into a
couple of worried folks but this is this
is really interesting because it gives
you an idea as you sort of scrolling
through as to what the the mood of it is
you know is this something which is
going to surprise me make me happy sad
and then that helps what I'm just sort
of doing my news browsing to decide
whether or not that's something I'm
likely to be interested in so we can see
people are pleased which is nice and the
other thing I wanted to highlight was
this sort of 3d view which is kind of
cool and this lets me browse categories
and so one of the big things about about
this particular app is that at Rustic
crosslink everything so there's a
particular topic that you want to read
about you can follow that train through
a bunch of different stories in the same
way that you would on something like
Wikipedia screw so you can go into
health
and then so for example here we can see
that there's a bunch of things which
have been highlighted so we can click
London 2012 and then it's going to find
us a bunch of news articles around that
and so you kind of get that Wikipedia
effect of being able to just follow the
trail of breadcrumbs so you can just
keep reading for hours and hours see
what the sex pistols are up to and maybe
I may be spoiling the olympic opening
for myself and others so we probably
shouldn't read too much more it's not
home but yeah I really like that and it
does a lot of those things right one of
the other things which I wanted to show
you real quickly let's see need to make
sure that I don't have too many other
things open on my other phone cuz I need
to reuse my real phone for this is so if
we switch to the to the camera fine
we'll see well I'll switch as soon as I
know you're not going to leak something
again where's the fun if we're not doing
things come on man Oh perfect oh wait
you should have seen that I'm kidding
alright so what we've got here is
actually one of my one of my favorite
things rich notification rich
notifications is richer than Android
notification rich notification boom and
so I discovered this by kind of by
accident this morning when I was just
playing around outside well you know
because I saw this and thought I really
like to read the rest of that but I
don't want to open up the app and so I
just gave it a try and drag her down and
boom there is all of the information I
need and it even has the ability for me
to and share or select my mood right
there for the notification screen this
is really really useful and I'm really
looking forward to seeing more apps
implementing these original ification
zand big props to the guys at Mobile's
Republic for you know building out this
dis stuff so quickly after the release
one of the things I like about this app
is that they do tend to follow all of
our new stuff as soon as we release it
so for me if someone who always has the
latest phone and the latest or wet right
I get to take advantage of this feature
straight away so thank you guys very
much appreciate that now it has been a
bit of a love fest if we switch back to
the to the tablet we've been talking
about all the good things about this app
one thing which I want to take this
opportunity to point out to them is that
they do fail one
my tests which is the zero latency so
it's pretty quick on the transformer
prime but I get this splash screen and I
get the splash screen every time I load
the app which is particularly painful
when I'm following one of their great
rich notifications so they have a great
notification system which every time a
news article pops up it tends to be
something I'm interested in because
you're able to customize what kind of
news you want to read and so it tends to
be something relevant for me and I'll
click it and have to wait two or three
seconds while it loads past the splash
screen which kills me so act by the time
that's happened on board I was just
going to relearn quickly while I was
waiting to do something else so if you
guys can figure out a way to remove that
that splash screen and that the
associated latency then you'll have
possibly about as close to a perfect
news reading well I always suggest it
that it could potentially use one of the
techniques that I already told you
earlier mentioned you can track when was
the last time the user has entered the
application and if it's you know only
two minutes ago you can just you know
bring back bring back up the previous
news items versus if the last use was
from you know 30 hours ago then you
might you optionally put up a screen
that that spins yeah so that's actually
really good point and one which I hadn't
even realized is that it doesn't go back
to where i was particularly if I'm
hitting the home screen like you know if
I'm here in the process of reading
through let's have a look so if i if i
go through have a look at all the happy
friendly news which sure if inputs on
the tablet you'll be able to see that
we've been able to select just good news
things which make me happy yeah
everyone's happy that stocks are going
up nice i know i am yeah and so you know
i'm in the middle of reading these
things and i go back to the home screen
to do something else check what time it
is and then go back you know i would
expect that to take me to exactly where
i was and it's dumped me back in sort of
the main home screen of the app and that
makes me sad so yeah that's definitely
so you want to work on as well perfect
ok so I pretty much all the time we had
because you know I went on at length
over the first app again so I'm going to
need to learn discipline
but that's that's all the time we have
today for news apps next week I think
we're looking at recipes I think recipes
this was a lifestyle I want a recipe app
I want an app which lets me browse
recipes store my own recipes all those
sorts of things that I have not been
able to find a great one so importantly
I'm going to be looking specifically to
pick out apps to highlight which let me
store my own app store my own recipes
and share them with other people not
just apps which provide excellent
recipes so I do check out the moderator
page and if you have an app that you've
been using that you think is perfect for
this please put it in there and we will
check them out next week sounds good
awesome so I stay tuned we've got in and
Dan for the friday game review I believe
they're looking at tower defense games
this week so that should be interesting
and they'll be on in just ten minutes so
stay tuned and we'll see you next week
same time looking at risk apps right